هذا هو
iPad الجديد ولأخبرك كل شيء عنه ، إليك
اللحن ،
هذا الآيباد الجديد مليء بالتحديثات ،
لذا دعنا نقفز
تحت غطاء المحرك هو شريحة
a13 bionic أكثر قوة وهي تدفع إلى أبعد
من a12 السريع من ipad العام الماضي
مع  20 أداء أسرع في كل
جانب من جوانب الشريحة من وحدة المعالجة المركزية ووحدة المعالجة المركزية
إلى المحرك العصبي
، ومعالج إشارة الصورة المحدث في
a13 يعني أيضًا أن الكاميرا الخلفية تلتقط
صورًا رائعة مع ضبط تلقائي للصورة محسّن في
الإضاءة المنخفضة وصور سيلفي أفضل من
الكاميرا الأمامية وكذلك
الآن  تعد الكاميرا الأمامية على iPad
ضرورية لأشياء مثل التعلم عن بُعد
والتواصل مع العائلة ،
ولهذا السبب يسعدنا جدًا أن نمنحها
ترقية كبيرة ،
فهي الآن كاميرا فائقة الاتساع بدقة 12 ميجابكسل
ميزة أخرى جديدة قادمة إلى جهاز iPad هذا
الذي يحبها المستخدمون وهي نغمة حقيقية  يقوم
بضبط الشاشة على درجة حرارة
لون الغرفة لتوفير تجربة مشاهدة أكثر راحة
، ومن خلال الاحتفاظ
بنفس التصميم الشائع ، يدعم جهاز iPad
مجموعة كبيرة من أجهزة التكييف  تشمل الملحقات
لوحة المفاتيح الذكية الرفيعة والخفيفة ولوحات
المفاتيح التابعة لجهات خارجية مثل
أحدث مجموعة متينة من لوجيتك مع لوحة التتبع
للمدارس ،
يقدم جهاز iPad هذا قيمة هائلة
لأن جهاز iPad الجديد يبدأ من 329 فقط
وهذا مع ضعف مساحة التخزين التي
تبدأ من 64 جيجا بايت
للمدارس.  بسعر مناسب بسعر 299
فقط ، يتوفر باللون الرمادي الفلكي والفضي ،
كما تتوفر طرازات خلوية ، كما
يمكنك طلب iPad الجديد اليوم
وسيكون متاحًا الأسبوع المقبل